[Music]
hello everybody this is international
Master Sam shankland and uh today I
would like to talk about how to become a
better Blitz player so it's a very
interesting question and it's there's
many strategies and you have to find
sort of the one that matches you but I
think
that basically there's two ways to
improve your Blitz you can improve your
Blitz by improving your chess just
becoming a better chess player and that
will translate to Blitz you know if you
see do tactics problems this will you
know help you in chess and in Blitz or
you know research your openings or study
end games uh both in regular chess and
in speed chess uh your results should
improve
but if you want to um just improve your
Blitz then it's kind of you can kind of
take a different strategy so there's one
uh person or character I know of uh
plays on ICC named Yakov norowitz and
he's a decent chess player uh he's about
2350 I believe USCF maybe 2300
F but in Blitz on
IC he routinely plays and does fine
against some of the best Grand Masters
in the world so the way he does it is he
has this same little thing it's sort of
a junk opening uh called The Stonewall
D4 D5 he plays a stupid move
E3 and something like Knight F6 F4 but
his point is here his plan is very
simple he's going to play moves like C3
Bishop D3 Knight D2 Knight F3 castle and
you know maybe he'll play Knight E5 and
try to force an attack uh for to for
example let's say black tries to play
aggressive C5 C3 Knight C6 Bishop D3
it's very hard to see how Black's going
to really even if we set up sort of a
king's Indian Knight F3 Bishop G7 castle
castle Knight D2 it's very hard to see
how Black's going to continue while
White's plan is often very clear let's
say maybe Knight to E 5 possibly bring
the uh not Queen F1 Queen E1 to H4 bring
the queen in it's very easy for white to
just make moves he doesn't need to be a
grandmas to play like moves like these
and
uh in other positions like for example
if you were to play D4 but do it more
conventionally like let's say D4 D5 C4
E6 Knight F3 Knight F6 Knight C3 Bishop
B4 we get sort of a Queen's Gambit
decline like very uh kind of very
interesting game and this is sort of the
type of opening that I guess you'd sort
of want to avoid if you're playing a
really good player because not only will
they know more Theory than you but
they'll understand the position better
and because for both sides here it's
going to be hard to find the best
move we hope you enjoyed this video demo
from chess.com subscribe today to finish
this video and get unlimited access
access to our full video library your
membership also includes access to chess
Mentor the most advanced interactive
training tool available anywhere you'll
also get full access to the opening
Explorer tactics trainer and much much
more so sign up today and get serious
about improving your
game